- So there's a new question
at the red carpet this year.
Forget who are you wearing?
- Who are you wearing?
- Who are you wearing this evening?
- Who am I wearing, oh Givenchy.
Do you do that to the guys?
- Now it's why are you wearing?
Because this year,
everybody's wearing black to
raise awareness of sexual
harassment in the industry.
There are already a ton of
celebrities that have promised to
wear black in support of the cause.
- I'm definitely going to
be wearing black for the
Golden Globes and standing with the women.
I'm bringing one of my
best friends with me and
she will be wearing black also.
(upbeat music)
- So Golden Globes, why
are they all wearing black?
- This year, after the
Harvey Weinstein story,
it kind of broke out in big public way.
A lot of women in Hollywood
were looking for ways to
take action and move forward
and out of that came the
Time's Up Movement which was
founded by a bunch of very
high-powered women in the
entertainment industry.
Say Time's up, we're not
gonna do this anymore.
We're not gonna let this happen.
They have a legal fund and
one of the prongs of approach
is to have people wear black
to the Golden Globes as
a show of solidarity.
- I think that there's a power
there that can be reached no
other way except for when
people fly in formation,
act as one.
- We're taking this seriously.
Here is a visual representation
of that on top of the
other things that they're
trying to do to make change.
- The whole sexual harassment subject
should be completely condemned.
There should be equal payment
and equal opportunities.
- I can't remember any award
shows where everyone wore the
same color dress but I'm
gonna be there in black.
- Fashion's always been a huge
part of award shows, right?
We have now a whole industry
of red carpet shows that happen
even before the award show happens.
- Hours and hours.
- Would you be my inaugural
Manicam, okay, right here.
I love that natural look.
- Congratulations, tell me
about your dress this evening.
- Well, it's pink and
there are stars on it.
- There are hours and
hours of shows that happen,
sometimes are even longer than
the actual award show itself.
Celebrities have really realized
that there's an opportunity
on the red carpet to have a
more nuance conversation than
the What are you wearing/who
are you wearing discussion.
- Yeah, because they're hours long.
- Pretty much only for the women on
red carpets at awards shows,
there's so much emphasis
put on their fashion
statements that they want to be like,
"Yeah, you're gonna talk about
our fashion but like this
time you have to mention how
it's connected to this big
thing that's happening to everybody."
- One of the things that has
happened in recent years is
that celebrity women have
started a campaign to say
ask her more which is to say, you know,
ask me more than who am I
wearing on the red carpet.
Women in the film industry want
to be taken more seriously.
The want to be perceived as
more than just designer clothing
hangers when their on the red carpet.
- This is a movement to, ya know,
say we're more than just our dresses.
- Hashtag ask her more.
- Highlight the fact that
women are multifaceted.
That we can talk about the
world as much as we can
talk about our gowns.
- Women wearing black this year
is kind of just an extension
of what's been happening
in the past years.
- I think there's always been
people that have used fashion
as a means to express political thought.
Joy Villa who has wore a
dress at the Grammy's that was
a maga-dress and had Trump on the train.
Then, you know, we see people
like Salma Hayek wear things
that are political or carry
signs because we are living in
such a controversial
politically striated time.
You're going to see a lot more
of that this year probably.
- You're definitely gonna
watch the Golden Globes, right?
- I'll be covering from the office.
- Are you gonna be wearing
black in solidarity?
- Maybe, I hadn't thought about that.
Maybe I'll, yeah, we'll see.
(upbeat music)
(sign creaking)